>> Okay Micheal. So we've talked about PCA
and ICA. And they both work remarkably well
in the specific domains that they're designed for.
And they've been applied for decades on a
wide variety of problems for doing this sort
of future transformation. But I'm going to just
very briefly describe two other alternatives, and sort
of give you a notion of the space, okay?
>> Sure.
>> Okay, the first one is kind of irritating,
but I feel obligated to share it with you.
Ad it's called, well it's got many different names, but
I'm going to call it RCA just because I like the symmetry.
And RCA stands for random components analysis. So what do you
think random components analysis does? This is also called random projection.
>> I'm going to guess, instead of finding dimensions with,
say, high variance, it's just going to pick any direction.
>> That's exactly right. What RCA does is it generates random directions.
>> Then I guess it projects the data out into those directions.
>> That's exactly right. It's like saying it picks a random
P to a random matrix to project your data onto. This
matrix is, in some sense, just any random linear combination. And
you want to know something? It works. It works remarkably well.
>> At what though? In terms
of like reconstruction?
>> At reconstruction. Well not particularly well at
reconstruction. But you know what it works really well,
it works really well if the next thing
you're going to do is some kind of classification.
>> Hm,
>> Now why is it you think that it actually works? Can you imagine why
just picking a bunch of random directions
and projecting onto those random directions might work?
>> Well, it does mix things together differently. I don't know why the
original data wouldn't work. Then this would
work better. Unless the original data is
somewhow is purposely made to not work.
>> Well remember what we're doing here,
right. We're starting with N dimensions. And we're
projecting down to M dimensions, where M is
significantly lower than N. So, I started with
a bunch of dimensions. Now remember, the real
problem here is not that I can't gather
the data from the N dimensions. It''s that
there's a whole bunch of them, cursor dimensionality.
>> Yes.
>> So I need to have a lot of data.
So if I don't have a lot of data, at least
certainly not an exponential amount of data, so to speak, and I project a
lower dimension, why would random projections still
give me something that helps with classification?
>> So it's, it's as if it's maintaining some
of the information from these other dimensions, even though
there's fewer of them now. They're all kind of
mixed together, but they signal might still be there.
>> That's exactly right. And because you project into a
lower dimension, you end up dealing with a cursor dimensionality problem,
which is sort of the whole point of this, or
one of the whole points of this in the first place.
And really, a, a way I think of summarizing what you're
saying is, that this manages to still pick up some correlations.
So if I take random linear combinations of all of my
features, then there's still information from all of my features there.
So in practice, at least in my experience, Michael, it turns
out that M, the number of lower dimensions you project into, for
a randomized components analysis, or randomized projections, tends to be bigger
than the M that you would get by doing something like PCA.
So you don't end up projecting down to sort of the
lowest possible dimensional space. But you still project down to a lower
dimensional space that happens to capture your correlations, or at
least capture some of the correlations, which often ends up
working very well for a learner or a classifier down
the road. You can actually see how, in this case, you
might even project into another set of dimensions M, where
those number dimensions are actually bigger than the number of
dimensions you started out with. This, in some sense, is
almost exactly what we did with perceptons in solving X or.
Basically, you're projecting into higher dimensional spaces
by doing this. Does that all make sense?
>> Yeah, I think so. I mean it makes sense
to me that it would be not as efficient in
some sense, as PCA, because it sort of reminds me
of, you know, if I want to, if I want
to paint my wall, I can very carefully paint all
the little pieces of it. Or, I could just splatter
stuff at it. It generally takes more when you splatter
because you're not being as systematic, but it does, ultimately,
cover your wall.
>> [LAUGH], Yeah. I think that's an interesting analogy, and I'm going to
go with an apt one. Okay, so, this sort of thing works. What
advantages does it actually have over PCA and ICA? Can you imagine one?
There's one in particular which I think sort of jumps out at you.
>> RCA? Well, I don't know. Is that, is that a good quiz question maybe?
>> Sure, let's make it a quick quiz.